can someone give me like a if you know
it like a one-sentence nice simple easy
definition for depreciation yes yes very
good okay so if something I'm gonna give
it a name by the way
I'm gonna call it an asset that's
something which that get sold on right
such as it's sometimes will lose value
right right
sometimes when something is new it's
more valuable and as you get older and
older in order it's like yeah you know
what this is not as good anymore not
everything does this by the way lots of
things appreciate in value rather than
depreciate value don't give me example
yes how's this real estate generally
appreciates yes why generally
appreciates right if very old wine is
very expensive yet coins okay so card
see things like that Emily things from
my childhood well they might appreciate
for you I don't appreciate the entire
what one will say okay so if you've got
some some mints like on untouched sort
of combing smokes all the kind of
collected use all pre here however
I'm sorry teacher
done this dr. Lane however most things
or a lot of things do not right as they
get older they MS and less value until
some point where it's like well you know
what this we talked about some examples
cars and computers
I probably the easiest like comedies on
the nuclear map and cars of course is
why it comes up in this now I want to
ask the question right and as I said
ages it loses value record depreciation
we're going to look at how do you work
out what its value is but my question
you guys is why does anyone care like
yes it does do that but why don't we
actually want to know what the number is
I can think of at least two big reasons
you don't want to throw my hobby yeah
okay so that because I love feeling
depressed about how much my things are
dropping back I know at least well what
is it useful to me to know that exact
fact that Holly's mentioned okay very
good so the first thing that we could
probably mention is do you remember arm
when I introduced this topic I showed
you this so I bought these cars I told
you I bought two of them views and two
of them new right now in order to work
out okay these prices that I paid these
were the prices are armies price is
reasonable or not
well the way you know is I can say okay
or if this is a 1994 Toyota Corolla
hatch and it's been you don't kept in
the carriage no I can I think but it's
very old
is that a suitable amount to pay for am
I getting ripped off right or is this an
amazing deal which by the way should
make you suspicious if anything that's
being sold to you like a used object is
an amazing deal you should be really
suspicious this Honda Civic is that is
so not that brand like is that about the
right
and for these objects here which are
brand new how much will I get back if I
end up sewing these things like Sigma T
or something like that okay that's a
2012 that's a that's of 2016
you know after one year how much is
gonna go with how much am I likely to
get back if Sam needs a afraid to like
I'm gonna be the car because we're kids
again Roger was facing about or whatever
it is so the first thing is like why
don't want to know like it's a bit
morbid isn't it like hey I'm losing
money every day it's very practical
purpose because you might want to
purchase something that someone else has
and you want to know how much value is
lost okay so we should actually write
that down I'm a reason number one reason
number one for why you need to know what
depreciation is it should be able to
calculate it is you want to be able to
have an accurate estimate of value if
you're purchasing if you're buying
something that has depreciated right you
want to not get ripped off basically
okay now there is a second other big
reason which is not immediate to you but
honestly it's um
it's a big reason for you when you start
earning an income and that kind of thing
do you remember all the way back in fm1
we talked about earnings and we talked
about deductions
do you remember what deductions are what
do you say deduction yeah
okay so this is interesting anyway just
knocks down the science right there are
these three kings that relate to each
other income deductions and taps you
know we have a really Darwin tax in
detail we're gonna do that in the HSC
course so don't feel like okay this is a
big idea I haven't dealt with this yet
that's okay
the point is in our country right there
is such a thing as income tax I should
point out there are some rare countries
in the world where there is no income
tax case but the more money you earn the
more money that the gun will take off
you certainly can't spend it on roads
schools hospitals all that okay however
if off your income you're actually
spending a lot of that on things you
have no choice about right so for
example I have to pay this membership to
the Board of Studies that's under $10 a
year or something like that to to make
sure that I stay registered you know how
we talk about registration cars
well teaches how if you're interested as
well I have to pay that I don't have a
choice otherwise it's illegal for me to
teach so being I have no choice my
income is not really whatever number of
thousands of dollars I it's actually
that and someone is being deducted now
okay so therefore I pay less tax because
yeah yeah that can come on your salary
your payslip not really equal now
depreciation is a really important part
of this okay reason number two is so
that we can send depreciation can be
counted I'll give you the citizen
spending can you count it as an expense
to reduce
okay so as an example right if I am a
traveling salesman okay so the fact that
I buy a car is not just because I want
to get from A to B but I've got to have
that car to do my job right so that's
kind of like a deduction right well fee
is like okay suppose I earn let's just
give me double so those are $50,000 a
year okay I could quite easily buy a car
that costs $50,000 right so does that
mean
oh free that year your income is 50,000
and we're just gonna deduct fifty
thousand dollars for me so you pay no
tax do you think the government will let
you do that no no they will not because
the system in shambles are very
difficult I'm inconsistent to collect
tax off people so what they say is okay
you know what that um the value actually
lose right is the amount that your each
year losing off the cut so imagine this
scenario if I bought that 50,000 long
time and then I just sold it the next
year I'm gonna get all this money back
and then I've paid their tax so they say
if for example you buy a car and it's
$50,000
a ruffed guess what do you guys think a
$50,000 car would be worth to progress
later after you've bought it just a
guess how many kilometers you've gone
back so it's lost the car yep so it's
lost $15,000 and thing okay now that
$15,000 that's a real expense right you
can't ever get that money back it's gone
right it's disappeared off into the car
okay so therefore that expense that's
smaller amount that can reduce your
taxable income okay now in reality
there's a few more complicated equations
in there but the point is I need to know
what the depreciation is not just so I
don't get ripped off we're buying
something but for my tax or if you're
running a business right you're going to
buy all kinds of things not just cars
and you
pay a lot of money to the government in
tax you want to reduce that